[Music]
your big fan of game shows is that right
a huge fan of game shows when what's
your favorite game show right now yeah
family feud with Steve Harvey it's
amazing people
this is not like good awful like the the
new kids on the block concert this is
good good it's just good television yeah
he's super super funny Steve positive
Harvey at the top of his game means
working with these families but the
families have gotten way dirtier now
like there when I grew up it was richard
dawson mrs. years ago and it was kind of
a tame show you're saying it's gotten
much dirtier now yeah it's so much
dirtier like they go what's one thing a
man can't live without and then you know
old woman - she's like penis you know
like okay calm down calm down old lady
we get it we get it and and you know
Steve Harvey's like okay penis penis huh
show me penis and then the board comes
up and it says schlong it's on the board
wait schlong is on the board you can't
you could say that I guess I actually
brought a picture of it I took a picture
on my TV there it is
TV his TVs chain I thought penis is out
of the room but schlong is in like who
are they pulling now like kids in like a
middle school parking lot yeah man yeah
everything what's a good thing to blend
in with fruit juices Shawn am I getting
this right you were becoming kind of an
action star that's your plan I what my
plan is that no one will cast me as an
action star like if I used to be in an
action movie
I'd be like the Rob Schneider part you
know I'd be like Channing Tatum the
computers are breaking we need to save
the day you know yeah be they part you
get it I do the nerdy guy yeah so I
created this show NTSF SD SUV where I
play like a Jack Bauer meets David
Caruso kind of action stars you know
some could do stunts and do all sort of
cool stuff but I'm learning I'm not
really cut out for it because we had
Lorenzo Lamas on the show action star
sure all right and and the stunt guy
comes over gonna have a big fight scene
in stunt guys like you guys uh need a
stunt man for this and Lorenzo Lamas
like no we don't need stunt men and I'm
like yeah we don't need stunt man okay
great
sure we're getting through this big
fight and I realized what Lorenzo Lamas
meant to say was I'm just gonna punch
you now like here like he was like um we
don't need stuntmen because I'm gonna
literally beat you up and he did he beat
me up and I faked it you know you're
supposed to like you never supposed to
make contact all he did was make contact
I actually had actually edited together
just the dailies from that day to show
you this is this is him lunch Oh Lamas
really hitting you every sound effect
that you hear is real this is not
reusing takes this is as many times we
did it you can take a look
wake up amigo I had a similar experience
where a couple of months ago I shot
something with Chelsea Handler yeah and
we're both in a shower and at one point
she's supposed to hit me
and I thought she was gonna do the the
fake yeah the hand comes across and you
do it in school and you just sort of
move your head and it looks like you got
hit you and I would be oh he doesn't
know about that so she starts hitting me
for real and I think okay I can take
yeah the director asked for literally 65
takes and she wailed on me oh my god to
the point where towards the end I was
like crying and my face was numb for a
day and this is this is that take a look
hit me just hit me Conan
this part is that kidding me this is not
good we need to do a stunt scene
together because then we won't hurt each
other look at me like this like that has
a faraway I don't like that I don't like
getting beaten up I want to be working
back on my computers that